the realm do you know what the realm is
it's the thousand blades of Aegon's
enemies a story we agreed to tell each
other over and over till we forget that
it's a lie
what's up ladies and gentlemen welcome
back for another game of thorns season 8
trailer breakdown video like I said in
my last video I want to take another
look at the trailer because I knew there
would be some things that I missed not
only that but I know a lot of you did
want to talk about it again now before
we get started I do want to mention the
sponsor of today's video this video is
sponsored by Squarespace
whether you need a domain a website or
even an online store I would highly
recommend that you check out Squarespace
you can find their link in my
description now let's take a look at
some of the scenes from the new Game of
Thrones Season 8 trailer the first thing
I want to talk about again is the
opening scene from the trailer this is
where we see a close-up of Arya Stark
what I really find interesting about
this is we hardly ever see Arya Stark in
that physical state
Arya looks terrified she has blood all
over her face and she is frantically
running away from someone or something
the main question everyone keeps asking
me is why is Arya running like that in
the trailer what the hell could be
chasing her now I did notice there are a
lot of fans debating about the location
of the scene some say she's at
Winterfell and some say she's at King's
Landing I happen to believe this is at
Winterfell during the big battle in
episode 3 that's why Arya looks the way
she looks Arya has suffered some
injuries during that attack they have
been fighting all night and an eye
king's army will eventually overrun the
castle walls there is some more evidence
of this happening in some of the later
scenes from the trailer now the fact
that we see Arya getting chased inside
of her own house means that the Starks
are on the verge of losing their castle
if you take a look at the weapon Arya
has in her hand then you can guess who
might be chasing her Arya is holding a
dragonglass dagger you can see that she
still has her Valyrian steel dagger
tucked away
I think if Arya was fighting another
living character then she would have no
reason to use the dragonglass
she would use one of her own weapons
that leads me to believe that Arya is
getting chased by White's or maybe even
a white Walker now let's take a look at
some of the other images because we may
be able to see what
is chasing her in one of these photos
you can see what appears to be two
different men chasing Aria through the
castle those men chasing Aria are most
likely whites from the night Kings army
they do not have the long hair like the
White Walkers now I know some fans have
said that Aria might actually know who
these whites are as in the night King
might have resurrected the stark dead I
think it's safe to say that anything is
possible but I do not think aria is
getting chased by Ned Stark or even
Catelyn Stark we are not even entirely
sure of their bodies made it back to
Winterfell
in the books Kaitlyn's body gets thrown
into the river but they never said what
happened to her body in the TV show the
last time we saw Ned Stark's bones was
when Littlefinger brought them to
Catelyn no one knows where they went
after that there was no mention of
Catelyn sending Ned's bones back to
Winterfell for all we know Walder Frey
could have done anything with Caitlyn's
body in Ned Stark's bones I highly doubt
that Walder Frey would have done the
right thing with either one of them so I
don't think we will see Catelyn or Ned
get resurrected by the night King
however there is always a chance that he
does resurrect some of the other stark
dead that are done in the crypts of
Winterfell now I know that these images
are a little blurry for any of us to
make out who is exactly chasing Arya but
I can almost guarantee they are White's
at some point during the big battle at
Winterfell the Starks castle will get
over ran by the night king's army like i
said earlier there are some images from
the trailer that show the whites are
making it over the castle walls there is
a scene where we can see brain of ptarth
fighting along the top of the
battlements at first I thought this
might have been Jaime Lannister but some
of you were right after I looked at it
again I am confident that is Brienne you
can see that she is cutting down White's
on top of the castle walls which means
the castle is coming very very close to
getting overtaken that means the whites
have already made it through several
lines of defense now let's take a look
at some of the other images because
Brienne is not the only one trying to
fight off the whites on top of the
battlements do you remember the scene
from the trailer where we saw Arya Stark
spinning around in circles well it also
appears as if Arya is up there fighting
the whites as well also take a look at
the weapon Arya has in her hands it
looks like she might be holding one of
the spears from the unsullied those
weapons are said to have dragonglass
tips on the ends of them it also looks
like Jaime Lannister might be fighting
up here as well
and I'm as
assuming this happens after we start to
see everyone running back inside a
winter Phil's gates there must come a
time during this battle where they can
no longer hold them off so they will
have to fall back to the castle and
fight from the battlements atop the wall
we know they won't be able to hold them
off forever because some of them
eventually make it inside the castle
where they begin to chase Arya Stark
I'm beginning to think the Starks may be
the last ones to leave their castle we
already saw varus hiding down in the
crypts of Winterfell with the woman and
children it even looks like Gilly and
baby Sam are down there with him like I
said in my last video there are secret
tunnels below Winterfell we'll make it
to the wall I won't make it 10 feet past
the Winterfell gates are always hidden
passageways built so the Lords of
Winterfell could escape these secret
tunnels were made that way the Starks
could escape their castle if need be
maester Luwin was telling this
information a Theon Greyjoy there is a
very good chance the Starks already know
how the access those tunnels
now Theon Greyjoy might not have known
about them but I am betting that Ned
Stark would have shown these to his kids
Melisandre even mentions that to Jon
Snow how can I help you come with us
when we ride south none of us know the
castle as well as you do it's hidden
tunnels its weaknesses its people
Melisandre knew that Jon most likely had
knowledge of Winterfell secrets I'm
thinking that Jon told all of the non
fighters to go hide down here until the
fighting was over but if the castle
would happen to fall then they would
need to use those tunnels to get out now
I want to take a look at some of the
other images I made a video a long time
ago where I tried to predict who I
thought would end up using Samwell Tarly
is Valyrian steel sword Hart's bane in
my opinion it did not make sense to have
Sam use that sword not when there would
be so many great fighters in Winterfell
at the same time as Sam imagine how much
more could get done if that sword is in
the right characters hands well it does
look like one of my predictions have
already came true sir Jorah Mormont will
be using Hart's pain during the big
battle at Winterfell you can see that he
has the sword in one of the images from
the trailer as we all know Samwell Tarly
and Jorah Mormont had an immediate
connection last season
Jorah Mormont's father G or Marmont was
the Lord Commander at Castle black when
Samwell Tarly was there he actually even
saved Samwell Tarly 'he's life when they
were out beyond the wall i think that
was one of the motivating factors that
led Sam to trying to save Jorah Mormont
from greyscale the last time those two
characters saw each other they did shake
hands and they said they hoped they
would see each other again so it does
make sense for Sam to let him use hearts
bane now that doesn't mean Sam gave him
the sword to keep forever
but he might have told him to use it
during the battle Sam knows that Jorah
is a much better fighter than him also I
know a lot of you were asking me about
the Dothraki soldiers they were not
heavily featured in the trailer but I
did notice them when I was making the
video if you look at the men riding on
the white horses behind him you can see
there are at least six or seven to three
key screamers on their horses I was
actually wondering how they would hold
up in the battle these Dothraki soldiers
are not used to fighting in the ice or
snow I wasn't even sure how well their
horses would be able to get around since
this is the second coming of the long
night I was expecting there to be so
much more snow but it doesn't appear
that way the horses seem to be running
around just fine another thing I want to
mention is there old friend grey worm I
have made some videos before where I
predicted which characters I think will
live and which characters I think will
die grey worm has always been on my list
of characters that I thought would die
next season and I think they might have
even highlighted this in the trailer for
some reason I just did not get a good
feeling when they showed grey worm give
him a sand a that kiss goodbye I am
thinking that might be the last time
they ever see each other which may be
why they decided to show him give her
that kiss there is something else from
the trailer that I want to talk about in
the video it actually happened so fast
that it is very easy to miss but for a
moment we do see a character holding a
bow I have been trying to decide who I
think this could be we know that type of
weapon is used in battle scenes but they
don't often show a close-up quite like
this that leads me to believe this could
be happening during a big scene but who
could it be
which characters have we seen using that
weapon in earlier seasons the first
character we have ever seen holding that
weapon is bran stark we see that in the
opening episode of the show now we all
know he's not very good at using a bow
and arrow but we do see him practice
over and over again during
dreamz bran has actually dreamt about
this many different times this always
led me to believe there was some
significance to this now that we see
someone holding the weapon in the
trailer for the final season of the show
then maybe it could be during an
important moment next season the only
thing is it looks like the character
from the trailer is standing up on their
two feet they could be on top of
Winterfell battle men shooting
dragonglass arrows at the army of the
Dead or even the knight Kings dragon
since they do appear to be standing up
then this probably is in brain stark but
it could be another stark we know that
arya stark knows how to use that weapon
in fact she was the one that hit the
bull's eye when we first saw brand
practicing in that opening episode not
only that but Arya even mentioned using
that weapon last season we heard her
tell a story about this when she was
speaking with Sansa
there was one arrow in the target there
was no one around just like no don't to
stop me so I started shooting and every
shot I had to go up there and get my one
arrow and walk back and shoot it again
maybe that conversation was
foreshadowing something Arya would do
next season now just in case it's not
Arya Stark who else could it be who else
have we seen used their weapon before
who else have we seen used that weapon
during a very big battle scene that
would be Bronn during the Battle of
Blackwater Bay bran was the one that
shot the arrow that ignited the Wildfire
now as we all know we did not see him
during the trailer but maybe that is him
holding the bow I did just want to point
that out because it might happen during
a very big scene there might be a reason
why they did not want to show that
character's face now let's move on to
some of the new information that came
out about the night king I did find this
to be rather interesting to say the
least the actor who portrays the night
king was interviewed recently about his
character and the final season he said a
few things during that interview that
some of you may find interesting and it
even sounds like we may know what he
wants the first thing it says is what
does the Nike 'none anyway the actor
said somebody made him the knight came
nobody knows who he was before a soldier
or part of nobility he never wanted to
be the knight King
I think he wants revenge everybody in
this story has two sides a bad side in a
good side the night king only has one
side a bad side now let's take a look at
the next question and answer what can we
expect from him in the final season
people will see that he has a target
that he wants to kill and you will find
out who that is there's also that moment
during hardhome when Jon Snow was on the
boat and the night king looked at him
and raised his arms there's a similar an
even stronger moment between Jon and the
night king this time so after I read
this my number one question was who the
hell is that I Kings target this could
explain what he is after for some reason
I don't think it's John because he would
not have talked about him and John
having another stare down in the very
next sentence that would make it too
obvious and not what essentially spoil
it I think it has to be someone else
someone we knew the night king has tried
to get before I know some fans might
think that it's gillies baby but I don't
think he wants to kill gillies baby we
know that he wanted those babies to
become White Walkers in the interview he
said the night King has a target that he
wants to kill I think it has to be bran
stark the new three-eyed Raven we
already saw what the night king did to
the old three eye Raven the night king
actually killed him himself that was the
first time we had ever seen the night
King kill someone personally every other
time he had the white so the White
Walkers do it but not when it came to
the three-eyed raven he wanted to take
him out on his own and I bet he wants to
do the same thing to bran Stark the one
character that could become more
powerful than him we have seen the
knight can grab bran inside of the
weirwood net but he was not able to kill
Bryan at that time the fact that Bryan
has the ability to use the weirwood net
just like the night king and the old
three-eyed Raven makes him a very big
threat this is more than likely one of
the causes for the night king to attack
Winterfell this is where bran stark is
at now we all know that brand knows he
is coming his uncle Benjen told him the
night king will make his way to Westeros
and when he does bran will be there
waiting for him and he will be ready one
way he will find his way to the wound
when he does you will be there way too
far and you will be ready let me know
what all of you have to say about this
leave your thoughts down below before I
go I do want to thank Squarespace for
sponsoring today's video for those of
you that don't know you can use
Squarespace to help build your own
website now I actually used to think it
was very difficult to build your own
website what Squarespace makes their
service very easy to use and understand
they do have an all-in-one platform that
even provides 24/7 customer support if
you were thinking about creating your
own website I highly recommend that you
go to Squarespace calm for your first
free trial whenever you're ready to
launch go to squarespace.com slash
talking Thrones to save 10% off your
first purchase you can find their link
down below they have also been a sponsor
of my favorite podcast for quite some
time so needless to say I was very
excited when they reached out to me
anyways I want to thank everyone for
watching today's video I really
appreciate that I also want to thank my
supporters over on patreon I hope you
all have a great day I will see you in
my next one bye
you